>> LEAK: Hi, I’m Bruce Leak. At Skypop,
we have a vision of a new class of mobile
experience, something that has never been
possible before, at least not before the Android
platform. I’m here with Timo Bruck, our
CTO, and he’s going to share with you what
it’s like being down and dirty day one on
the Android platform.
>> BRUCK: So on day one, like most engineers,
I got that every platform started running
our little world, and I ended up with a pseudo
code game. I just bypassed our little world
all together, come out with a nice graphic
to all applications. I've never had anything
like that so fast on a mobile device. The
platform is just that easy to use. Day two
is like, okay, well, what am I going to do
with this platform? So I kind of took the
location APIs and the view and map APIs put
them together and wrote a friend-finder application.
You can see where all your friends are. You’d
get maps just like Google maps in the web,
but it’s on your cell phone. You have a
little compass down here in the corners to
help you find them if you want to try to,
you know, navigate the maze. It’s kind of
like, you know, the starship, it's your tri-quarter
but to find friends instead of finding aliens.
So then I want to take it to the next step.
I was like let’s use kind of friend-finders
plus games. What can you do there? So then
I came up with an idea of just doing kind
of a team geocaching. You know, you already
know where your friends are and know where
your opponents are. You can draw a map that
has the location of the cache, it has your
friends. You can send little taunting messages,
you know, when you think your foes are not
really catching up to you. And again, I focus
to spend my time just working on the application,
on the creative part I wanted to do. Everything
else was provided by the platform, so it was
a lot of fun, productive and you know, what
a joy to work with which was a pleasure from
a little device.
>> LEAK: We, at Skypop can't wait for the
first Android devices to hit the market so
that you can see what we’re really up to,
and so that we can see all the great things
that you're going to develop. See you soon.